round seven of the Ziegfeld Cup the most  exciting tournament up here here in st.  Louis with only three rounds to go and  all of the play for the best players in  the world had to bring their a-game in a  race to the finish line five-time world  champion Vishwanath on Anan tried to put  the big squeeze against Jana bumpy on  cheese and a mistake by the Russian  allowed another of the point and leap  into a tie for first the boner onea and  coolly be back in opening novel sidecar  una Senora when the pride of Armenia  mathroom  the winning combination destroy the  leader then it's AB annulment round with  three players tied going into the home  stretch  trout ain't action coming up next  [Music]